en georgia la batalla por los 16 votos
electorales es un reflejo de su
diversidad demográfica con pronunciadas
divisiones raciales y una brecha entre
las poblaciones rurales en los anillos
exteriores que tienen al rojo de donald
trump y las grandes ciudades de mayoría
demócrata los republicanos han dependido
tradicionalmente de los votantes blancos
para abrumar a la gran parte de los
votantes afroamericanos del estado sin
embargo las zonas con una densidad
demográfica blanca están ahora divididas
entre ambos candidatos con un avance del
demócrata en aquellos lugares donde la
mayoría de residentes blancos no tienen
títulos universitarios job aiden
mantiene el apoyo de las comunidades
afro y el azul tiñe las grandes urbes
como el área metropolitana de atlanta de
mayoría afroamericana y sus suburbios
kirchner el esfuerzo aquí es asegurarnos
de que el voto de todos el voto legal se
ha contado correctamente y que los
resultados reales reflejan la intención
del votante el problema aquí es que
tenemos una votación muy reñida
pensilvania adjudica 20 votos
electorales con 12,8 millones de
habitantes el estado tiene más del 75
por ciento de población blanca durante
los últimos años las mayorías de obreros
blancos
en las bases de votantes demócratas pero
el declive de la industria manufacturera
y el éxodo acompañó el reconfigurado
mapa electoral pensilvano y dio la
victoria a trump en 2016 la clave es
ahora filadelfia bastión demócrata en
nevada donde han votado por los
demócratas desde 2008 el cambio
demográfico del estado es decisivo cada
año los votantes de minorías constituyen
la gran parte del electorado
favoreciendo a los demócratas como el
hispano con uno de cada cinco votantes
latinos en 2016 pero el voto rural es de
trump